se ha anunciado como inminente desde
hace semanas pero la contraofensiva de
las fuerzas de kiev podría de hecho
tardar más de lo previsto
Esto es lo que reveló el presidente
ucraniano en la cadena británica bbc
lo más importante es proteger a nuestro
pueblo estamos esperando tener el equipo
blindado adecuado con lo que tenemos
podemos seguir adelante y tener éxito
pero perderíamos a mucha gente
creo que eso es inaceptable así que
tenemos que esperar todavía necesitamos
un poco más de tiempo y ya vamos luego
una retórica que contrasta con la de
hace unos días
a finales de abril el ministro de
defensa ucraniano decía que las tropas
estaban casi listas
los preparativos para la contraofensiva
están a punto de concluir además de
armas y equipos militares nuestros
soldados también necesitan tener control
sobre ellos y hemos recibido sistemas
muy modernos el sistema
municiones y equipos suministrados poco
a poco por occidente como los misiles de
largo alcance anunciados este por Reino
Unido Hoy puedo confirmar que el Reino
Unido va a entregar misiles Storm Shadow
a Ucrania La donación de estos sistemas
de armas proporciona Ucrania la mejor
oportunidad para defenderse de la
continua brutalidad rusa en el frente de
los soldados ucranianos siguen
resistiendo en mahmud epicentro de los
combates en el este controlado en un 95%
por los rusos por su parte el líder del
grupo Wagner cuyos hombres siguen
atrincherados en la urbe asegura que la
contraofensiva está en mar